hey guys it's Justine and today we're
unboxing the Samsung Galaxy Note 8 kill
the music time in the comments and on
Twitter
fighting with Android users and it's
silly because I'm not sure if they
realize that they're not trolling me I
don't care that you think that Android
is better than iOS I don't care that
Apple fans think iOS is better than
Android it's never-ending dilemma it's a
fight that I just don't really care
about fighting I like what I like you
like what you like and guess what that
is perfectly fine no one's gonna be
criticizing you for your favorite color
I mean this shouldn't it I mean my
favorite colors black and then I get
criticized because black is not a color
it's the internet I don't know when I
will learn that you can't ever make
everyone happy I'm sure many of you are
confused because the iPhone is coming
out tomorrow so Justine why are you on
boxing the Samsung Galaxy Note 8 I did
an essential phone of boxing and a lot
of you guys were like well where's the
no date unboxing and I was like I don't
know here it is I plan on doing an
extensive test between all of the phones
that I have now I can add at the Galaxy
Note 8 to that test in the essential
phone unboxing I did the s8 the pixel
the essential phone and my iPhone so now
let me I've owned a comes out I will
have an arsenal of test footage from all
of these phones to sort of go through
and pick what I like the best let's hop
right into this unboxing and get this
thing all set up so I can start to test
it out so before the iPhone comes out
unfortunately I'm going to be traveling
the day that the iPhone is released but
put on your calendars for Saturday and
some
and pretty much every day next week I
will be putting out a bunch of iPhone
videos all next week so stay tuned and
follow me on Twitter Instagram and
whoever else it is that I post that
stuff like that Facebook too so I love
having a second phone as an Android
phone because I love that everything
integrates incredibly well with Google
YouTube email I love doing email on
Android because I feel like the Gmail
integration is always extremely seamless
so I'm going to be looking forward to
testing this out in the coming weeks
here it is it's got a nice feel to it so
the size is not that much bigger than
the s8 but I do feel like if you have an
essay you're probably not gonna be
switching to an O date unless that's the
type of person that you are so let's
turn this guy on the Nonie is a little
more rectangular where this has very
nice curved edges which I think I feel
like I do sort of like this look a lot
more setting up facial recognition all
right so here is the setup screen and
what's interesting is this is very
different from the setup screen on the
new iPhone X my face has been detected
okay setting up facial recognition on
any iPhone X is kind of interesting
because you will be looking at it and it
makes you go through a series of motions
rotating your head making sure that it
gets the entire view of your face I'm
doing it like I'm actually doing it
right at home I'm just remembering at
the Apple event what the setup looked
like look at this pitch that's something
you can't unsee kay facial recognition
swipes screen to unlock it's unlocked
just so excited I love technology so
let's take a picture of you guys now
let's try to live focus and this is
something I'm really excited about it's
basically the same thing as portrait
mode on the iPhone so I'm gonna take a
picture of you wow this looks really
good actually so here's the picture that
I took this is kind of a really
difficult photo to distinguish between
what should be in focus so here's the
background focus so you can turn it all
the way down or you can turn it all the
way up if you guys can tell the
background is completely blurred out
just have some kind of like filter on
cuz why is my skin look nice oh yeah it
definitely does I was like I'm a bad
skin or anything but like it looks real
good
oh my god well if I was on any of those
dating apps this would definitely be my
profile picture look you can slim your
face I can make my eyes bigger but
what's wrong with how I am I mean look
at all these options it's basically like
you're not good enough let's fix you all
right so let's turn everything all the
way discern the skin tone all the way up
that looks good I'm so blurry you can't
even tell slim my face I'll make my eyes
big I kind of look like in the Moriya
Brothers movie the goombas I just take
like a normal picture oh my god all the
effects are still on don't want large
eyes I want mine I'll take a normal
picture hi I'm normal but I love a lot
about the Samsung phones is the
front-facing cameras are very wide angle
okay let's do a little video test before
I end this unboxing video image
stabilization looks nice you see Mike
while this is very smooth like when I
move this it almost looks like it's on
some sort of glider I wonder if it looks
like this when I watch it playback now
let's flip it around and see what the
front-facing video looks like hi it's
Justine you didn't know yeah my si
filming this little video on my Samsung
Galaxy Note 8 it's already taken a fall
I don't think there's any damage but it
definitely took quite a tumble and the
sound that it made I thought it
shattered if it was but it didn't still
here and I've only had it for 24 hours
we're gonna test out some of the photo
and video features so Jana would you
like to be a model for me or what sure
sure Wow alright it's much like the
iPhone 7 plus this has dual cameras
we're gonna be using live focus which
allows you to blur and D blur the
background while taking the photo and it
post and it's windy alright are you
ready for live focus yes what's that
mean don't move
my focus is available okay wow this is
struggling a lot because of the
background we have fun no my eyes are
watery does the wind yeah yeah it
actually looks really good looks like
I'm going to school my school picture it
does look there's a little bit of non
blur right there so okay that's a little
much but to be fair this is pretty good
so here's what it looks like with a blur
all the way down all the way up
mid-range the only the mid looks pretty
good because it blends it pretty well
with your hair third so that's what the
picture looks like without we need
healthy background blur look how much
better it looks with the live focus yeah
way better
it's my school picture okay let's see
I'm Jason oh look at that - you're a
really skilled normal picture oh my gosh
it's crash very lovely trash lovely now
let's try out the portrait mode on the
iPhone 7 plus and see what the
comparison is between the portrait mode
and the live focus oh yeah
the note looks better
I'm shocked you made me take a few more
maybe maybe you just got to take it a
different way
so there's one
looks pretty good around your hair
background background it sometimes
struggles with my blonde hair but I feel
like on yours did a really good job look
at that I'm having so much fun today
yeah definitely struggles with blonde
hair
Skrillex now let's do a quick little
video test oh gosh Oh No Wow
my phone's recording notes recording
there's Jenna
here's my feet boat this is real fast on
this one no like look at this I'm
filming my phone what are all the audio
is how do you think the audio is did you
like to tell us a story it's not in
front of me that's on the screen yeah
that's a good story but it's a great
story how about the ice cream and today
I don't want to talk about that look at
this dog
which what do you like the best one of
the biggest difference between this and
the s8 of course other than a price the
screen is a little bit larger but it has
a stylus have you seen my stylus
probably four people are gonna get that
joke this is cool you can do a bunch of
different things screen right I'm gonna
do a live message it's basically like
the app will watch live messages yes
okay you're so close like at you hit
anybody oh god I screwed up already
delete what's that gonna show up on my
phone has I don't know let's see okay
it's preparing its preparing preparing
that compression looks like trash here's
what it looks like it looks really bad
like why you bother the actual live
animation looks incredible but then it
turns it into the chip which is very
very low quality not sure if there's a
way to change it to make it look a
little bit better that looks bad right
I'm not impressed
frankly your condo if this is not my
hanok a disaster another thing that I
like is if your phone is locked and you
take a stylus out it'll automatically
open up this note says little memo
screen so you can basically take notes
without unlocking your phone and then
save them it's what I wrote
[Music]
well this is the note that I wrote Jenna
it's a real piece of work
I'm sorry
let's try a screen right so this is art
all right I'll save it
no and I accidentally move my pen over
here who was I doing mean I'm gana I'm
Jana I didn't set up the iris scanner
cuz it told me to take my contacts out
and I was like well then I can't see
so I'll just maybe set that up later
[Music]
okay
oh it's such the Reds
why they look so bad ruins of a moment I
was really impressed with the no take
camera the live focus feature is
incredible I was really surprised how
well the photos turned out especially in
comparison to the portrait mode on the
iPhone but but that being said I'm gonna
be really excited to put this thing up
against the iPhone X and see how the
photos turned out so it's got a lot of
stuff we've got a USB to USB C adapter
and we also have a USB micro to USBC
adapter I lose these every single time
nice fast charge this one is just a
regular USB which is actually kind of
nice because I have a bunch of regular
USB to USB C cables this I don't know if
this is a kg headphones these headphones
are pretty good I got a pair of these
with the SA and what I like about them
is it's kind of this graded material
which I feel like helps this last a lot
longer when you kind of are abusive to
things and you travel a lot and you
throw these in your bag I carry these as
backup headphones I use them a lot when
I'm playing right into the switch
so I know I'm kind of a hypocrite
because I have a clear case on my SAT
and that's one of the things that I have
said many times that I do not like I
don't like clear cases because crap gets
stuck inside of them but so far this
case has held up pretty well I think
because it's a very very tight fit on
this phone that nothing is really
getting inside of it so that's a very
similar look to the note 8 except you
can tell there is a very big difference
with the cameras the fingerprint sensor
is in the same place 11 just like the
unboxing the node 8 because I wanted to
let you guys know that I'm checking it
out and what I have planned for the rest
of the week and to not be alarmed why
there's not an iPhone video it's because
I'm traveling but I do have an iPhone
video plan for tomorrow it's just know
the iPhone 8 yet I'll be unboxing some
accessories for the iPhone 8 and the
Apple watch so come say hi check that
out and hopefully you can be patient
until the next day when I return home to
my new iphone 8 let me know in the
comments below what phone you have what
you guys think of the iPhone 8 what you
guys think of the note 8 what you think
of the iPhone X I'm sure there's going
to be a lot of fighting in the comments
building
it's marijuana I look forward to reading
all of the wonderful comments that you
guys are going to have about everything
so I'll see you soon hey does it
[Music]